well what we have is perception
management going on and so the submarine
thing the Titan and the Titanic all of
this is a is a great window into this I
don't know what really happened there we
know we're being lied to we know the uh
Navy and the Coast Guard have incredible
sonar that area in the Atlantic's
heavily covered because nuclear
submarine stuff and they know the
signature of an imploding vessel it's
been studied heavily and they also know
the sound of it hitting the bottom I
mean they can hear somebody thumping on
the side of a submarine of three
thousand miles away and they've got
signatures this is there's there's been
hundreds of billions of dollars put into
the to These acoustic sonar systems
other things
and they've got even more advanced stuff
like that that deals with these giant
antennas they've got strung out that are
sending waves to the Earth that it's
beyond sonar that pick all this stuff up
it's just it's insane and so they knew
exactly when it imploded they knew they
were dead they they knew about the
wreckage and they and the commander said
we reported it's not our job talk to
media and they decided not to tell you
yeah and so they just decided to leave
it out there there's a distraction with
all the 100 Biden stuff coming out just
like they indicted Trump Jack Smith did
the day the last big trunch of Hunter
Biden stuff came out so don't let a good
crisis go to waste were they in the
submarine they really die I mean we get
lied to so much who knows am I going to
get sued for seven point or 2.75
trillion I mean all I know is I'm saying
I've been lied to so much I don't know
but I know this
my phone blew up my text messages I've
never been asked in a short period of
time so many times since since Monday
what do you think really happened
uh with the submarine and that shows
people don't buy it and almost everybody
says I don't think anybody was on it or
I think they knew they were already dead
I was hearing this on Monday and oh
they're already dead they know they're
dead they're just gonna have this like
the boy in the well and so everybody
focuses on it and I'm like I don't know
so I didn't comment until Friday because
what I've learned is they spin when I
just question and war game something and
then say look he says nobody died and
they'll go to the Widow one of the
submarine guys go look he's up there
making money saying nobody died and then
they'll then they'll I mean literally
that's that's the model but what's
happening is the public doesn't believe
any of it almost no one I talk to like
No One Believes it so you ask your
question is you know what's the biggest
thing we expose or how does this mind
control work I think we're coming out of
it we have a discredited corporate media
we have a discredited uh government
that's been hijacked the Public's really
ending their naivete and figuring out
they've been lied to and beginning the
Journey of discovering what's happening
I think popular podcasts and shows like
yours uh that are really I think middle
of the road but are actually just
looking at the facts are going to lead
the way out of this as the New Media is
now the mainstream media I mean you know
your show's bigger than most the shows
on cable Joe Rogan's show I think
something like 50 times bigger than a
CNN show uh you know 15 times better
than a fox show and but but why do we
still call it the mainstream media why
do we still sit all they are is
disruptors that sit there and use
psychological warfare to manipulate us
and so it's very healthy that people
don't believe anything they're told
that's your right especially when you've
been lied to so much if I had a neighbor
that lied to me once I think they were
weird they lied to me twice I'm not
going to talk to them anymore these
people have been lying to us caught and
then laugh about it how funny it is I
mean take James O'Keefe last year
about a year and a half ago this is a
full year before they totally shut it
down
well we're going to end the whole coven
thing and stop hyping that for now and
we're going to be all global warming and
lockdowns and energy shortages and
collapsing stuff and you know you know
just the end of civilization into the
world and then like a light switch they
a few months later
all the media on the same day gets the
new script to shift to that well that's
the dinosaur media and the only Power
they have is getting us to kind of
debate what they're saying and doing
when at a certain point you realize it's
just all crap and that's happened the
average CNN show has like 80 000 viewers
uh the the the fox has lost half their
viewers at least they're down from an
average of two million viewers like less
than a million they're all committing
suicide you see Anheuser-Busch
committing suicide uh but then uh Modelo
smart we want to celebrate Sports Heroes
and icons and War veterans and families
and Heritage and and then and then like
it's not just Hispanics going on buying
the beer it's the white people they go
yeah we want to celebrate Heritage too I
mean we just we want to crack a beer and
think about you know our country and our
mothers and fathers and sisters and
brothers and children how we're good
people and how we want to be successful
we want to hear about a boxer or a
swimmer or a firefighter that save kids
we don't want to see some clown hop
around the dress and we're sick of the
demoralization so they're attempt to
demoralize us is not demoralizing us now
it's causing the Great Awakening so so
you know when you're saying that here's
how I process it so take somebody that's
watching this and saying I cannot
believe these guys are hosting Alex
Jones this guy is the platform from
everywhere Twitter even Elon Musk
doesn't have Alex Jones which book I'm
going to ask you about that as well and
wait a minute but so so so there there
are the people that 100 agree with you
they're loving what you're saying like
oh this is awesome great keep going it
and then there's the people in the
middle like yeah kind of let me you know
kind of makes sense and the people on
the one side that you're not going to
win anyways I just want to talk to the
people in the middle forget about either
side I want to talk to the people in the
middle so if you're like me
as a middle eastern Alex I'm naturally
super skeptical I'm a paranoid guy I
don't trust a lot of people okay I'm
kind of like well what's the guy's
motive
etc etc but here's the part Rob we've
shown this before here's Publix trust in
the US government from 58 to today it's
the lowest it's been look at the numbers
right there I mean I've I think the
lowest it hit was under Obama if you
look at it there and then now
from there kept going kept going kept
going it hasn't increased now go to the
public trust in mainstream media which
is even worse we were all the way up at
you know 75 percent in 1976 give or take
and it has gradually declined all the
way down to 34 so it's not and by the
way I've looked at these big National
polls they're still sampling more
Mainline people so from the numbers I've
seen and what they internally have they
can do with these algorithms it's way
worse Congress is more like five percent
and I mean trust in Congress yes and you
pull that up and the media is nine and
by the way these numbers are from Gallup
it's not exactly some random question
is is is is is is is from what we've
seen is is it's worse than what's what
they're saying but here's the part
though even with Gallup for Gallup to
show 2007 I mean seven percent Americans
have common or Industries failing us
okay so so what's the key word there
that we're not trusting institutions
establishment okay like people are
wondering and nowadays even college
education is it even worth for me to go
to college what am I going to go to
college for and that's why they want to
watch a new show check what it's saying
and then they basically Knight that as
the new show like yours or Joe Rogan
because because they trust you does that
make sense yeah so so they've committed
suicide and they think destroying us
will make them be risen from the dead
they could take us all out new people
will pop right back I think I think what
people want is to listen to other
skeptical people I think Joe's skeptical
I don't look at Joe and I'm like you
know Joe's a you know a guy that's fully
trying to push an agenda I think Joe
Sanderson guys I don't know what's going
on here I'm going through the product
like the way you opened up skeptical and
he is curious I love the way he's very
curious I love the way he opened up the
RFK interview where he said I'm not
going to lie to you for the last five
years you know when I would watch
sometimes this guy's a cook this guy's
this I'm like okay probably not and then
all of a sudden I'm like wait a minute
some of the stuff he's saying is true
and then I read the book and I'm like
holy [__] and then we ran into each
other at the it's funny the same
restaurant we were at but it was myself
him and RFK Casa D'Angelo and we have to
give a shout out to Casa D'Angelo Aspen
we were just a day apart
so so that's how they connected like hey
I want to get you on the podcast and
then obviously when he did the podcast
he pissed off everybody hey if you
enjoyed this short clip you want to
watch the whole thing click over here
but if you want to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life I host a conference once year it's
called The Vault conference where 3 000
CEOs executive entrepreneurs from around
the world come together to strategize
for three and a half days this year it's
going to be at Miami Diplomat Resort and
the speakers this year is going to be
Tom Brady he'll be there I'll be
interviewing them Mike Tyson will gudara
the guy that ran 11 Madison in New York
if you run a business if you're a CEO
entrepreneur and executive this is not
an event you want to miss out on get
yourself your spouse your business
partner your running mates registered
and I look forward to seeing you there
click on the link here or see the link
in the description and I hope to spend
three and a half days with you in Miami
in August September take care everybody
foreign
[Music]